yeah this is huge this is massive right
watch what this means think about like
gonna be here I think about this guy I
can state this in exactly the same way
that I stated this okay let's think
about this guy now admittedly I've
chosen examples which were very easy to
get just the numerical methods but like
as soon as we go I'll climb the ladder a
little bit you'll get some ones which
it's a lot a trapezium it's a lot of
circle it's nothing easy okay
so here this will look a little bit
awkward but watch this is no I've
already written that I want to say this
is gonna be F of the upper boundary
takeaway F of the lower boundary do you
agree with that okay so here's my upper
boundary which is conveniently the same
and he's my lower boundary you're right
with that so what I want is this take
away this do you agree with that okay
now what I need to know is well what's
the primitive what happens when I add
you differentiate that guy okay so this
is this is where I'm going is it where
I'm leaning okay so in order to get back
I'm gonna say well hmm
this thing in here are for X what do I
differentiate to end up with X try and
do this in Reverse there it's gonna be x
squared the power goes off and then I
divide right you agree that gets hot x
squared very good cuz if I differentiate
this guy I'll get 2x what do I
differentiate to get 5 that's the
primitive button the answers 5x okay you
write with that one okay now I'll get to
the plus C in a second
I want you notice I've set a primitive
right but you guys know there's an
infinite number of periods right it
could be this plus 0 could be this plus
100 could be this plus 150 in a minute I
would justify for you why it doesn't
matter
hold on for a second okay now I need to
choose a bit of notation Yeah right this
is my capital F this is capital F so
what I do is I want to evaluate this at
two different spots so we try to borrow
this kind of down language
and we put a box around it like this and
say I want to evaluate that at three and
then take it away from evaluating it at
negative one
no this is new this is completely new
the first time centers so now I can
write this light right this is my
capital F which is three squared on two
plus five times three that's capital F
of three and I take away capital F of
negative one so that's gonna be negative
one squared
five lots of negative one okay
that's F of three that's F of negative
one okay that's where I ended takeaway
where I started you okay so far let's
just crunch the numbers okay
this looks to me like nine on 2 plus 15
this looks to me like a half minus five
yep nine and two is four and a half four
and a half so that sounds like nineteen
and a half to me take away negative four
and a half which is adding four and a
half nineteen huh
what's four and a hub sounds to me like
the answer I already knew for the fact
that it was a trapezium now just hold on
what did we just establish right through
this understanding of speed distance in
time which is just one lens through
which you can understand gradient okay
we learnt the to go from this function
to this function you differentiate
differentiating tells you gradient okay
but to climb back up right this process
of anti-differentiating it gives you
area right going back up this way is
what we call integration because that's
the problem it's solving you're trying
to put together all of these things so
you have one piece an area okay
differentiating digi gradient
integrating gives you area right the
opposite like area ingredient that it
seemed like they would be opposites to
each other
but they are okay so this idea here this
is the crucial insight in fact this is
called the fundamental theorem of
calculus that you can do this kind of
thing more generally speaking rather
than all of this if I didn't know it was
1 3 etc I would say I'm saying let's not
a any know me like and it'd be any
number you like integral from A to B of
any function he's gonna be go to the
primitive go to whatever you integrated
up to right what have you
sorry 80 different units up to and
evaluate your upper and lower boundaries
and that will give you the area okay now
you remember I said you you raised a
great question at this point when I
wrote this down you said hey wait a
second sure that's a premium that's a
capital F but it's only one of them like
there's an infinite number of other
things in the family of primitives I
wonder if you can see at this line why
it doesn't matter which primitive I
choose okay as mark says whichever
pretty much choose what they differ by
all the different premiers what's their
difference just the constant the
constant term right so let's pick
another one say I don't know mine five
sure why not let's say x squared on two
plus five x plus five is the actual
premium I'm interested and I'm going to
evaluate that from negative one to three
okay so now I do now I do this this like
here right
and a lot of it is still the same it's
still 3 squared on two plus five times
three plus five days real constant right
but then when you take away the same
plus five comes along for the ride right
and whatever comes you choose if you try
this negative ten or PI or 18 you it's
always going to get added and then
subtracted so you can choose any period
it doesn't matter okay that's amazing
now what that corresponds to by the way
is remember we said down here 25
kilometers per hour right that area
there is the total distance
what difference does it make from where
I started as to the total distance I
traveled and the answer is doesn't make
any difference like here I don't know
maybe that's like 70 or something like
that I have no idea actually needs if I
started it like zero right down here and
I just still traveled at 25 kilometers
per hour
I'd still travel in that two hours and
still travel 50 kilometers the area was
still the same right so therefore it
doesn't matter which primitive you take
any questions okay now remember that on
question we started with right we were
trying to look at a particular area
namely not to of x squared DX that was
this guy remember I can't remember that
now just really quickly you do with many
um
we looked at some approximate ways of
doing it we divided up into four sets of
rectangles okay now we can actually it's
not that hard we can work out together
especially as you pretty free we can
work out what Riemann sums would have
been right we can work out what they
would be for example let's do the UM
let's do the little rectangles the blue
okay we already know what the width of
each of those rectangles is going to be
each one will be a half right okay I
need for this particular case I've got
three rectangles because the first one
has no area no big deal so what's the
area of the on behind the first
rectangle going to be this is it x
equals 1/2 so it looks to me like that
would be 1/4
do you agree with that it's 1/2 square
okay the next one over is that x equals
one and it's x squared so it looks like
is gonna be a 1 so that will be one and
then the last one what will its type a
the value is going to be x equals three
on two and then when you square it you
get nine on four UK with that so I have
three rectangles they all have the same
width okay and then they have these
hunts a corner one and what would you
say - okay let's work out this actual
area now
actual area exactly right up here is my
function I need to deal with the
primitive of the seniors
what's the primitive of x-squared how it
goes after Erie power goes up and then
you divide by that power that's the
reverse of what we do a differentiation
right you slightly box around it and you
say okay what am i offering low of
Alex's Mansu and zero okay yeah so now I
evaluated right the first one will be a
on three that's the upper bound and then
I subtract your zero on three so I get
this versus what would you say 1.75 now
well way up
of course we're way off because we
really four chunks right we can quickly
as well we can work out what the upper
rectangles are too it's not that
difficult again there's going to be
they're all gonna have with the Huff
okay at the hub but we've actually done
a lot of work already
have you noticed we've done all of the
work I already know it the height of
this first rectangle made gonna be a
quarter off right I already know it's
the height of the second rectangle be
it'll be one I already know that you
getting this nine over four what's the
last one it's x equals two x equals two
right
so when I square that I should get four
okay I'm not going to trust myself to do
this is time what are we gonna get for
some point that sets three point seven
five right
and there's our actual area pretty much
bang in the middle do you see that do
you see it yeah so I'm so glad you
connected all right so this process of
trying to work out areas right we start
with trying to try to sum things up
right but in fact this gigantic tool
you've been developing all year namely
in calculus differentiation you can use
it in Reverse to find out area
right I have congratulations you just
learnt the one skill that is pretty much
gonna take you through the entire HSC
course right